قال رئيس الاداره العسكريه في كيف انه من
غير المستبعد ان تشون روسيا هجوما جديدا
انطلاقا من بيلاروسيا مؤكدا في الوقت ذاته
ان التدريبات العسكريه الروسيه
البيلاروسيه الحاليه لا تشكل تعديدا
مباشره لاوكرانيا واعلن جهاز امن الدوله
الاوكراني انه اجرى تدريبات عسكريه واسعه
النطاق في المناطق الحدوديه مع بيلاروسيا
حاكت سيناريو ستيلاء قوات روسيه على منشات
للطاقه وتحييد مجموعات حاولت اختراق
الحدود
من جانبها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع البيلاروسيا
رفع الجاهزيه القتاليه لوحدات المدفعيه في
اطار عمليات ما يعرف بالمجموعه الاقليميه
للقوات المشتركه الروسيه بلا روسيه وكانت
الخارجيه الروسيه قد اكدت في وقت سابق ان
المناورات العسكريه مع بيلاروسيا دفاعيه
بهدف ثاني من سمتهم الخصومه المحتمله عن
التصعيد نقلت وكاله تاسع عن مسؤولين في
الخارجيه الروسيه تحذيره من ان استخدام
القوه العسكريه من طرف نظام كيف او غزو
الجيش الاوكراني لاراضي في بيلاروسيا او
روسيا يعتبر سببا كافيا للقيام برد جماعه
قال الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ان انخراط بيلاروسيا الكامل
في الحرب الى جانب روسيا سيكون خطا
استراتيجيا خطيرا للغايه واوضحت لينسكي في
تصريحات تلفزيونيه ان مهمه روسيا هي جر
بيلاروسيا الى حرب هشام الى على اوكرانيا
وان مهمه بيلاروسيا يعدم القيام بذلك
واضاف انه لا يزال بوسعي بلا روسيا ان
تتجنب الدوره التي اختارته روسيا لنفسها
وان ما سيحدث بعدها يعتمد على قرار منكس
بشان ذلك